[Música]
bom dia hoje eu faço locomoção no futuro
eu escolhi esse tema porque é uma coisa
que me interessa muito e do meu ponto de
vista é uma coisa que poucas pessoas
sabem ou se interessam bom mas já antes
de falar do futuro eu gostei de voltar
um pouco no tempo e falar como era
antigamente essa imagem mostra um
bondinho que quer já no rio de janeiro
ele é diferente muito trem trem e
elétrico
devido a esse trio que passa em cima
dele e alguns dias depois é para cumprir
agenda em 2016 criarão vai ter o veículo
leve sobre trilhos
ele é também elétrica e e como muitos
carros de hoje em dia não fazem barulho
nem poluem e nessa imagem podemos ver
três carros diferentes
o primeiro é um dos primeiros modelos
que fizeram ele é é movido a combustível
fóssil como a segunda imagem
o terceiro é um carro elétrico que vai
ser carregado
se vem freando ou é tomada
bom aqui no final e ver o carro autônomo
o que é um carro tão bom o carro
autônomo ele é um carro que não precisa
motorista algum e pôde andar pela rua é
que ele não está aberto ao público mas o
que está sendo desenvolvido e vai ver
algum dia os carros autônomos e eles no
futuro e se eram conectadas por uma
inteligência que é irá conduzir cada um
dos carros
assim é e irá diminuir
noventa por cento de acidentes e oscar
pereira andar em uma velocidade muito
maior
ocupando espaço e no futuro vão ser
desenvolvidas carros
sem esses que o que podem eo vovô a
proximidade das ruas
bom enfim acho que é uma das coisas que
que pensam que pensou muito no futuro
que nós podemos ver em filmes mas que é
bem difícil fazer um carro que não vou e
e com eles
então espero que algum dia possa
desenvolver a tecnologia e sem é poluir
o meio ambiente
obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]